- [Narrator] This is the A100
chip from the US giant NVIDIA.
It's one of the world's most
advanced computing processors,
which helps develop artificial
intelligence that's used
in everything from self-driving cars
to making drugs and even building weapons.
And this is one of its
newest competitors made
by a Chinese startup.
Industry analysts who track the speed
of chips say this model is
even faster than the A100
based on initial tests.
- It produced performances
that were significantly
more competitive than previous
AI chips coming from China.
- [Narrator] Here's how
the design and capabilities
of these two chips compare
as the race for dominance
in tech is ramping up.
(pensive music)
The US has been a pioneer
in the semiconductor
industry for over 70 years.
- The US essentially gave birth
to the semiconductor industry
and the semiconductor economy.
- Wayne Lam is the director of research
with tech consulting firm CCS Insight.
For over a decade,
he has been researching
American chip technology.
- [Wayne] The US was an ideal place
because it started much at the
research and core sciences.
- [Narrator] In the late 1940s,
American scientists invented
the first transistor,
the fundamental technology
behind all chips.
Early versions of chips
fit inside computers
that helped calculate projectiles
and get NASA space
programs off the ground.
(lively music)
But the industry really took off
in the 1960s with the rising demand
for consumer goods like televisions
and corporate computers.
That boom also drove chip companies
to spring up across Asia
with Taiwan Semiconductor
Manufacturing Company
now leading the industry, making more
than 90% of the world's
most advanced chips.
Still today, the US is home
to some of the world's
leading chip designers
and they help power everything
from our smartphones to
laptops and data centers.
China, on the other hand,
has long been trailing the US
and for several decades
it has actually relied
on American companies,
as well as chip makers
in Taiwan and Japan.
In 2021, China imported more
than $430 billion worth of
chips, exceeding that of oil.
So Chinese President Xi Jinping
has made it a top priority to change that.
- It's absolutely important
on a strategic basis.
- Gregory Allen is a senior fellow
at the Center for Strategic
and International Studies,
a think tank based in Washington, D.C.
He's been following Beijing's AI
and semiconductor policies
for about seven years.
- [Gregory] What they essentially wanted
in the semiconductor industry was for more
of the chips that were used
in China to be made in China.
- [Narrator] So to
become more self-reliant,
Beijing promised to
provide about $180 billion
in state funding to support
its domestic chip industry.
The goal is to design
chips that can be as fast
as the American ones like
this AI chip from NVIDIA.
And this model released in August
by Biren is the latest
demonstration of China's progress.
Like its American rival,
the Biren chip is also a
graphics processing unit,
or GPU, and both are designed
to help computers perform
complex tasks faster.
So what makes a chip powerful?
To improve their performance,
both companies are using
the same type of transistor.
It's the fundamental unit that
basically controls the flow
of electronic signals
and that allows the chips to
store data or run calculations.
But unlike the first transistor
invented in the 1940s,
the ones today are so small
that they are measured in nanometers,
which is a fraction of
the width of a human hair.
Seven nanometer transistors
are now the base
for both NVIDIA and Biren's high-end chips
- So smaller to the transistor,
the more transistors you can pack
into the same surface area of a silicon.
- [Narrator] The American chip is designed
with more than 54 billion transistors
over a plate of about
800 millimeters square
whereas the BR100 is slightly bigger
with about 77 billion transistors packed
into about 1,000 square millimeters.
While there are many
factors that determine
a chip's performance,
industry experts say having a
higher number of transistors
can help increase the
Chinese processor's speed.
Biren says its chip can perform more
than 1,000 trillion operations
per second at its peak.
Write it out, that's 15 zeros.
That's about three times the
stated speed of NVIDIA's A100.
But whether Biren will be
able to dominate the market
will require more than designing chips.
Producing them is also a huge challenge
because it requires precise manufacturing
to squeeze these billions of transistors
onto a tiny surface.
- Semiconductor manufacturing is perhaps
the most technologically complicated thing
that the human species does.
- [Narrator] One of the
most complex processes
is called lithography,
which blasts UV light through photo masks
and prints patterns on silicon wafers,
adding layers to form the transistors.
- You need to be precise.
Some of the layers
in the semiconductor transistors
are only one atom thick.
- [Narrator] So NVIDIA and Biren both look
to another company for manufacturing.
You may have guessed,
that's the Taiwan Semiconductor
Manufacturing Company,
the world's largest
contract chip producer.
But Biren's reliance on TSMC
is becoming a hurdle on
its way to rivaling NVIDIA.
- Has been sort of a cautionary tale
for the Chinese semiconductor industry.
- [Narrator] A couple of months
after the Chinese
startup release its chip,
the Biden administration
imposed new export restrictions.
The rules barred cutting-edge
semiconductors made
with American technologies
from being sold to China.
And because TSMC uses
equipment from US companies,
Biren is at risk
of losing the Taiwanese
chip maker as a supplier.
- This dramatically
reduces Biren's prospects
for its future as a leading chip designer.
- [Narrator] Biren didn't
respond to a request for comment.
TSMC says it complies with
all laws and regulations
but declined to comment
on specific customers.
China also depends on a handful
of American companies
that dominate the industry
for advanced manufacturing equipment.
With the American
government blocking China
from buying these machines,
it becomes even harder
for Beijing to build its own
high-end chip making factories.
- That development is a Herculean
effort to say the least.
So it would require
considerable investment
in capital and time to make that happen.
- [Narrator] China isn't alone
in facing challenges in trying
to become more self-sufficient.
While the US leads in design and research,
it has also long relied
on outside manufacturers
like TSMC and Samsung in South Korea.
And the vulnerability of that
dependence became an issue
during the pandemic when a chip
shortage hit companies large
and small, prompting
President Biden to promise
that more semiconductors
would be produced in the US.
- This is infrastructure.
So look, we need to
build the infrastructure
of today, not repair the one of yesterday.
- [Narrator] So in August,
he signed the CHIPS Act,
allocating more than $52 billion
in federal aid for semiconductor
research and manufacturing.
TSMC later announced that
it would invest $40 billion
to build two factories in Arizona.
- These investments are helping us build
and strengthen the supply
chain here in America.
- [Narrator] And only
months after the release
of China's BR100, NVIDIA announced
that it will release
a super fast new chip,
which would in turn beat Biren's.
The long and expensive race
to develop chips that'll drive the future
of AI is entering a new phase.
(pensive music)